[Music]
what's that we're going on another trip
a very tiny bedroom and one day we're
going to sing command Fuji it's a bit
over
cast so maybe it clears up I don't know
I don't know well we see it well who
knows
follow along
[Music]
unexpected to stop there's a cool
Lakeside music thing here we're checking
out we're almost right by the hotel it's
really pretty around here
we never actually went surprisingly
around Mount Fuji yet so it's cool to
explore it's way different different
vibe mountains all over it's really
pretty
foreign
[Music]
we just arrived at our little glamping
spot it's super nice
and the sun just came out as well Mount
Fuji is covered
maybe tomorrow it's one of those things
you you have to be a little lucky to see
it and that's our little sleeping tent
is your check inside I love the door is
so tiny
oh it's an actual tent
all right
oh wow it's super cute
it's bigger than it looks like they
trick you with a small door you sleep
there
yeah I can't believe this is a tent what
it's
it's hard yeah it's so much clearer now
there's still got snow on it
huh
we were hoping maybe we would get like a
red man Fuji for the sunset but I don't
think that happens this time of year
foreign
[Music]
I love the zucchini
I like crispy
[Music]
come from a crusty can
you know thousands of data Brokers have
secret shadow profiles of you and they
include a frightening amount of details
online privacy data is our currency and
some of the buyers are actually in the
business of selling your data over and
over again
it's really surprising to me how
companies can take your private
information
valid and somehow that's legal this
information can be used by scammers
strangers insurance companies Banks
businesses even the government and they
can all use this information against you
while also making a good profit out of
it where's my money my money apparently
my email address is worth 89 to any
brand I want that 89 the good news is
you can remove it the bad news is it
will take you over 300 hours to do so
opting out of this has been made
Difficult by default and that's where
incognit comes in all you got to do to
get your personal information removed is
sign up pay a small bit amount of money
and sit back and relax and let
incognitive do the work
it's a really great service and I
recommend you guys check it out to
protect your privacy incognit will take
care of it all for you and you can track
it easily online and I know what you're
thinking Felix this sounds great can you
cut me a deal though of course right now
if you go to incognito.com PewDiePie you
get 60 off from what I can tell it's a
very competitive price if you guys use
the offer so I recommend taking
advantage now so click the link below to
get your personal information wiped off
the internet as it should have been from
the beginning thank you incognate for
sponsoring this video
this tent is so cozy that was really
nice I would definitely come back here
tomorrow we're going to uh park now
we're gonna watch a movie good night
Gamers I'm gonna fade down the light so
it looks like it says good night there
you go
[Music]
foreign
I love the Fuji accounts
[Music]
put into Mount Fuji when you have this
one right there
[Music]
it's ramune
it's a soda and pineapple
and it's Pokemon so I am 33.
mmm
or Cutter chewy bits in it
did I use it right she told me how to
use it
[Music]
we stopped by a village on the way here
it's very old style traditional
thank you
[Music]
you found a big bug that's a stink bug
Momo
that's disgusting do not kill it
yeah it probably didn't taste good did
it
lesson learned Momo
they are insects are coming to Japan
I don't like it
something you don't like here mama
she's freaked out by something
someone's a little
are you on edgemo
is it the New Year's rape so I'm just
putting up the
things that will hold up the shelves and
I got a little helper here hello
all right all done
we'll get so much more storage now
we're happy with that took a little less
than an hour that's so much better
and now we have space for more
board games
[Music]
I forgot I pre-ordered it is usually I
go for a digital versions
the legend of relatives of the Kingdom
the reason I pre-ordered it
it's not for the game this goes in the
trash
is for things
if you pre-ordered it in Japan you get a
spoon
way better
it's a nice spoon
some say it looks like any other spoon
but it says Legend of satellite on it
it's spoon it's gonna be worth billions
I'll leave this tonight thank you
laughs
what the hell
oh my God
you're lucky you got in the car earlier
I don't have a drop on you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
oh
yeah
is there any ice cream
I don't know I don't get it
wow yeah
surprise me
they're all we're all surprised
[Music]
this time they have chocolate which is
my favorite to grab a chocolate
you look like a little strawberry as
well
[Music]
uh
foreign
spots in inside Tokyo would still
outside very very pretty and I won the
lottery they were like oh
I'm like what did I win
all right it's very cool
this is Martinez so cute I'm gonna try
and paint this PJ what you got
um
very nice
[Music]
they look great it's such a nice day
today it's like a comfortable
temperature no too hot I took my parents
here and it was way too hot and it was
the day after we went surfing so I'm
glad we get to enjoy it again
and not suffer the whole time
[Music]
hello hello
open air music
I've been here before it's really nice
what are you doing you're ruining my
shot go far away
[Music]
thank you
all right so let's head up yeah
[Music]
thank you
we stop down
[Music]
thank you
some people stop to pet
Mama that guy
so I took the chance to ask them where
the pun was but I didn't realize it was
so far and they were like we'll guide
you so they walked this all the way
they're so friendly of them oh man I
said sorry I'm not good in Japanese and
she was so nice she was like but you
spoke to me a little bit I was like yeah
but yeah a really nice park this is
where the Ghibli museum is uh it seems
like it's already quite popular
[Music]
thank you
that looks good
[Music]
sparkly dolls
my sister spotted a bird everyone's
looking at the bird
s
where
that's it
more more
[Music]
thank you
it's the first time Momo meets the ocean
[Music]
excited Mama it's water
almost be careful that's disgusting
they're like tsunamis for you Mama
[Music]
thank you it's time to come back and
serve and with me my co-partner Mr
ball himself what up looking gay it
doesn't fit
[Laughter]
that look cool action shine all right
we're going in the waves are looking a
little a little [__] they look huge but
I don't know like
we'll see how it goes it's not gonna be
surfing
the most amazing footage
rolled their waves perfectly
best footage ever
I lost the GoPro sorry it's and it was
Chris GoPro
my daughter's first birthday was on she
will never know what it was like
you know there's an expectation to go if
I won't be coming back from the battle
thank you I appreciate that I'll get you
a new GoPro stop complaining come on
I want the brand new top of the range
GoPro oh okay all the trimmings what do
you got there Chris don't worry Felix in
my line of work we always bring a spare
oh thanks you can build yourself
crashing once again don't lose it
thank you Chris thank you what a pro
[Music]
really tell but it's getting a little
darker we've been surfing for like hours
it's so good one last stretch I feel
like being a kid
there she is
this is like the most beautiful evening
it looks amazing
[Music]
what an affable gentleman look at him
the sunset hit and all the sky just blew
up orange it looked like it was on fire
it was so beautiful and then the ocean
itself became pink because of the
reflection and the waves are so nice it
was a jaw-dropping I was stunned I'm so
thrilled that was amazing
I'm so tired we've been out for hours
check my lost a GoPro I had so many good
ways on that he shot off the water for
the showers damn that's YouTube money
Evian very nice desperation
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow huge
thank you
we're at a bookstore we read this one
it's Pandora it's really cute and they
have merch here
oh God
we're going to uh their aquarium thing
it's really cool looking inside
[Music]
oh
we're seasoned here now we've been here
three times or months it has I don't
know if you remember from earlier vlogs
Senpai wow
big boy
[Music]
they look so hideous and cute
oh God
I love the music
[Music]
and thick boy
he's got that ass
[Music]
glow me Summer happy mid-summer today's
mid-summer the greatest Swedish
tradition
so of course we're going to IKEA
to have some meatballs
yes
home
hey oh my God
it's like they speak my language
oh my God
what
they have it
oh my God they have the whole thing I
can't believe it I think you have to
reserve for that
wow
they have veggie meatballs and they look
good usually they put corn in them but
not even in Japan the land where they
cook corn and everything
I was never a fan of these or the
gromplice
I don't really like them but oh you're
getting one the dime cake
it's like I'm home it's like I never
left I can't believe they were actually
celebrating
it's good it's funny to me because a lot
of people like they're like oh I love
meatballs at Ikea I'm like yeah the
worst meatballs you can get they're not
bad this is the flavor we have for the G
fuel
and it's really tart and it goes so well
with the Savory
very happy for this boy right now gotta
try out the Kenyan bullet it looks bad
I'm not gonna lie
it's hard it's supposed to be soft
sorry for hating Ikea
that's not too bad
Columbus summer Happy mid-summer from me
and eggy yeah you look so cute again
I'm almost too crazy to have one
we did it
Spyro 100
all right what do we get what do we get
this is
what you collected all the coins here's
your reward collecting more yay thank
you so much
hey I get glasses
just wanted to say it's getting very
close now very close to becoming a Dan
I'm very very very excited I don't know
what it's going to be like I don't know
if I'll have time to make videos this is
going to be chaos I don't know but I
imagine I will not upload in a while so
just want to say thank you for all the
support in these Vlogs we're so happy
that you guys enjoyed them and we can
share a bit of our life here but I think
for now we might take a little break
until we come back again and uh yeah
just wanted to let you guys know thank
you
[Music]
you got in my shot PJ get out of the shy
what the hell oh my God he's [__]
tourists